-Maya!
-Hi.
-Oh, it's so good to see you.
I like -- Oh, my gosh.
I love your hair.
I miss seeing you.
-Thanks, bud.
I know. I love you.
-Even though I just saw you
on "Saturday Night Live."
I love you, bud.
Congrats on "Saturday Night
Live" last weekend.
I want to walk through
some of the steps
because I can't
even really imagine
all of the steps that went on.
First of all, it's the first
show back in a pandemic.
-Yeah.
-What was it like?
I didn't want to go up
and bother anybody.
-It -- It was nuts.
I mean, you and I were there
for the first show
after September 11th.
-Yeah.
-And when anthrax was
in the building, I believe.
-Oh, yeah.
-That was another doozy.
-Do you remember that?
-That was crazy.
And I feel like there was
a reminiscent feeling of
there was -- you were in the
center of everything going on.
And honestly, "SNL's"
been doing -- they're doing
an unbelievable job
of making you feel safe.
Everyone's tested every single
time we walk in, but it's "SNL."
Everything happens
at the last minute,
you know, in order to get the
best show possible on the air.
So imagine that with,
like, PPE and masks
and people spread apart.
It's wild.
It was so strange
and yet so comforting
because the minute
you're in that building and you
hear the music, you're like,
"Oh, life's back to
normal again."
-Yeah.
-With just some
little alterations.
-How was the script
and cue cards?
How do you deal with rehearsing?
-Dude, that's also crazy.
I mean, think about it.
Think about our
beloved cue card crew
having to write everything down
and then changes
but in a time of molasses.
So they're like -- you know,
with masks everything is slower.
-Yeah.
-The protocol's slower.
I think scripts are on iPads
right now, by the way,
which is also
like a future language
that you and I
never experienced.
We're used to, like,
you talk to somebody.
They write it down.
They get it to scripty.
They get the changes in.
They go to cue cards.
I didn't see my lines that
I said on the show until air.
So it was really scary.
-No way.
-It was so scary.
I was not even thinking about
what Kamala speaks like.
I was just worried, like,
"Do I have pants on?
Are we -- Is -- Like, is there
a booger hanging out?
Like, is everything okay?"
And then, later on, I was like,
"Well, there's the impression."
Me, like, terrified
out of my wits,
looking at the wrong cameras,
like I was out of my body.
-No, it was perfect.
You had pants on and you nailed
it, by the way. It was great.
-I'm so grateful, always,
to be a part of that place.
And then, like, when,
in my wildest dreams,
did I think there would
ever be a candidate
that looks remotely close to
whatever this is?
It -- The whole thing is --
-It just worked.
-And I realize, like, I started
working there 21 years ago.
How am I still standing?
-Yeah.
Isn't it great?
-How am I still standing?
Yeah.
-I love it because you're funny.
-I love it.
-When Vice President Biden
announced Kamala Harris
as his running mate,
you were, somehow,
on a Zoom interview thing
or something, live.
You can't write this.
And you're on live,
and somebody says,
"He just chose Kamala Harris."
And you were so human and so
real, your first reaction was...
-Was, "Oh, [bleep]."
-Yeah.
-You know why? Because we're
in the middle of a pandemic.
-I know we are.
I know we are.
-I was like, "How am I
gonna get to New York?
Oh, [bleep]."
-Yeah.
-That's complicated.
That's really complicated
because it's my civic duty.
I got to do it.
I got to get there
and do whatever I need to do
to make sure
that she wins this election
and also that I do a good job.
And how the hell do I do that?
Because I haven't left my house
in seven months.
-You did a virtual event
with Senator Harris,
and Amy Poehler was there
and Hillary Clinton.
-How about that?
-All at the same time.
Was that your first time me--
-That was nuts.
Yeah, that was the first time
I met Kamala and Hillary.
We don't hang out that much.
I have never met
those incredible women.
And it was bananas,
and it was so cool.
We were just, like, chatting
about quarantine,
asking Hillary about quarantine.
She was like, "Ah, I've been
catching up on sleep."
Like, the coolest --
-Yeah.
-"Hanging out with
my grandkids."
And then poor Poehler's sound
went out and she was so upset
'cause, you know, she is ver--
she's a very, like,
professional lady.
And she was not pleased
that her sound went out
'cause it was not her fault.
And I was trying to, like,
come up with, you know,
like, do some, like,
wacky shabba-shabba.
And I said,
"Man, it's sabotage."
And right away
Hillary chimed in.
She goes,
"It's probably the Russians."
-Oh, nice!
Score.
-For the win. Score.
-She shoots, she scores.
I love it.
-What a stud.
-Well, speaking of scoring,
how about this segue?
You scored so hard as Kamala
that, my friend,
you won an Emmy
for that performance.
So, congrats.
I'm not the only one
who thinks it's awesome.
-Thank you. Crazy.
-Then you won another Emmy!
You won two Emmys!
-Yes.
I double-Emmy'd.
-You double --
Have you -- I know you've been
nominated before.
Have you ever won before?
-I've never won anything
in my life.
Like, I won -- I won that first
Emmy for "Big Mouth" really,
truly, genuinely, like,
not expecting anything.
And then I was
nominated for "SNL."
And I was like,
"Ooh, now I want another one."
Like, I became an addict,
like, overnight.
-You got the bug.
-I was like,
"I want to win again."
-Yeah.
Well, it's about to go down.
-"Give it to me again."
-Yeah. Give it to me again.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk to you about
"Hubie Halloween."
-Okay.
-Alright.
More with Maya Rudolph
when we come back, everybody.